This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In January of 1981, Ronald Reagan took office as the 40th President of the United States. His first day, like most presidential first days, began with a tour of the White House. It's said that while Reagan was being escorted around the grounds. He had one particular request. He wanted to see the war room. You can probably conjure up an image of the war room in your head. An underground bunker with ominous overhead lighting, a large circular table, and a big map of the world hung up on the wall. But here's the thing.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1981年1月，罗纳德·里根就任美国第40任总统。像大多数总统上任的第一天一样，他从参观白宫开始。据说，当里根在白宫内参观时，他提出了一个特别的要求。他想看看“作战室”。你脑海中可能已经浮现出了作战室的样子：一个带有阴森顶灯的地下掩体，一张巨大的圆形桌子，墙上挂着一张巨大的世界地图。但问题是：
That war room simply does not exist. It's not in the White House. it's not in the Capitol Building. Not one room in the Pentagon remotely resembles the war room Reagan had in mind. But Reagan believed it must have existed because he had seen it somewhere. And that somewhere was the 1964 Stanley Kubrick film, Dr. Strangelove. Am I to understand the Russian ambassadors to be admitted entrance to the war room? Are you aware of what a serious breach of security that would be? I mean, you see everything. You see the big board.
那个作战室根本不存在。它不在白宫，也不在国会大厦。五角大楼里没有任何一个房间能与里根心目中的作战室相提并论。但里根相信它一定存在，因为他在某处见过它。而那个“某处”就是斯坦利·库布里克1964年的电影《奇爱博士》。我是不是该理解为要允许俄罗斯大使进入作战室？你意识到这将是多么严重的泄密吗？我的意思是，你什么都看到了。你看到了那块大屏幕。
The design was so iconic that it's become our mental image of where we think important decisions should be made. Airbnb and the soccer organization FIFA have since built their own replica war rooms modeled after the film, which is ironic given that Dr. Strangelove is a farce about the destructive insanity of the nuclear arms race. But that is the power of a good movie. What we see on the screen has this way of influencing our perception of the world, which makes sense because the average American spends two hours and 51 minutes watching movies and TV each day. That's a whopping 19% of our waking hours.
这种设计太经典了，以至于它成了我们心中关于“重要决策应该在哪里做出”的心理图景。此后，爱彼迎（Airbnb）和国际足联（FIFA）都根据这部电影建造了自己的复制版作战室，这很讽刺，因为《奇爱博士》本身就是一部关于核军备竞赛破坏性疯狂的闹剧。但这就是好莱坞电影的力量。我们在银幕上看到的东西会影响我们对世界的感知，这很合理，因为美国人平均每天花2小时51分钟看电影和电视。这占了我们清醒时间的19%，比例惊人。
We conceive media as sometimes just a thing that's just kind of rolling or the ambient noise of our lives, things that we do to distract ourselves or turn our brains off. And what I contend and what the evidence kind of largely backs up is that this stuff is actually really meaningful This is Walt Hickey data journalist and author of a new book called you are what you watch Walt makes the case for how much film and television shape us as individuals and as a society far beyond what we give them credit for I Say that you are what you watch because obviously it's alluding to the idea
我们有时认为媒体只是生活中背景噪音般的存在，是我们用来分散注意力或让大脑放空的东西。但我所主张的，且有大量证据支持的观点是，这些东西实际上非常有意义。这位是沃尔特·希基，数据记者，也是新书《你就是你所看的内容》（You Are What You Watch）的作者。沃尔特论证了电影和电视在多大程度上塑造了我们个人和社会，其程度远超我们的想象。我说“你就是你所看的内容”，显然是在影射“人如其食”的理念。
that you are what you eat, but it was just kind of consistently struck how often I found people whose lives were meaningfully or permanently changed by a thing that they watched or people who encountered an idea that ended up changing the course of their lives. Today, Walt is here to talk about the delightful, surprising, dark,
但我一直感到震惊的是，我经常发现有人因为看过的东西而使生活发生了有意义或永久性的改变，或者有人接触到了某种最终改变了他们人生轨迹的观点。今天，沃尔特来到这里，要谈谈电影和电视以令人愉悦、出人意料、黑暗、
and sometimes counterintuitive ways movies and TV shaped the world around us, and how the world we live in influences the movie world right back. Take for example the space race. Immediately after World War II, most people were really skeptical of space travel, and rockets, they were mostly known as deadly weapons that leveled cities during wartime. The notion that we might strap a human to one and send them to space was pretty out there. But that all changed thanks to a popular magazine and the Disney Corporation.
有时甚至是反直觉的方式塑造我们周围世界的过程，以及我们所处的世界又是如何反过来影响电影世界的。以太空竞赛为例。二战刚结束时，大多数人对太空旅行和火箭持怀疑态度，火箭在当时主要被视为战时夷平城市的致命武器。把人绑在火箭上送入太空的想法在当时看来简直是天方夜谭。但这一切都因为一本流行杂志和迪士尼公司而改变了。
It took, essentially Collier's magazine at the time had a massive circulation. It was one of those popular magazines in America. And a journalist from Collier's had the opportunity to meet Werner von Braun at a conference. Werner von Braun was one of Nazi Germany's top aerospace engineers. After the war ended, von Braun, along with over a thousand German scientists and engineers, were secretly brought to the United States to lead our space race mission. And so, you know, over the course of a number of conversations, this becomes a series within Collier's magazine that is read by millions that is essentially
当时《科利尔》杂志拥有巨大的发行量。它是美国最受欢迎的杂志之一。一位《科利尔》的记者在一次会议上有机会见到了沃纳·冯·布劳恩。冯·布劳恩是纳粹德国顶尖的航空航天工程师之一。战争结束后，冯·布劳恩和一千多名德国科学家及工程师被秘密带到美国，领导我们的太空竞赛任务。所以，经过多次交谈，这在《科利尔》杂志上形成了一个系列报道，被数百万人阅读，其内容本质上是
detailing, Hey, not only is it possible to get to space with rockets, it's also possible to get to the moon and explore further beyond that. The series was ambitiously titled, Will Conquer Space Soon and ran between 1952 and 1954, and among its many readers was the pioneering animator and media mogul, Mr. Walt Disney. And then Disney is obsessed with this. And then all of a sudden, on his nationally broadcast Disneyland television show, has three different episodes featuring Von Braun as well as a number of other scientists, but adapting, here's what could actually get us to space. Here's how we can use rockets to get there.
详细阐述了：嘿，用火箭不仅可以到达太空，还可以到达月球并进行更深远的探索。该系列文章雄心勃勃地命名为《我们将很快征服太空》，刊登于1952年至1954年间，其众多读者中就包括开创性的动画师和媒体大亨沃尔特·迪士尼先生。迪士尼对此非常着迷。随后，在他的全国广播节目《迪士尼乐园》中，他制作了三集不同的节目，邀请冯·布劳恩和其他几位科学家参与，改编并展示了：我们实际上如何才能进入太空，以及如何利用火箭到达那里。
Here's what it would be like in orbit. Here's what it means to be in orbit. And here's how one could hypothetically get to the moon and back. If we were to start today on an organized and well-supported space program. I believe a practical passenger rocket could be built and tested within 10 years." And these have a remarkable effect, because if you look at by the end of the decade, all of a sudden Americans now fully believe, oh yeah, we can get to the moon. And then over the course of the 60s, they really start to, you know, obviously believe that it'll happen within their lifetimes and within potentially by the 1980s and then very soon, very imminently.
进入轨道会是什么样子？进入轨道意味着什么？如果我们要从今天开始一个有组织且支持充足的太空计划，假设我们如何才能往返月球。我相信一架实用的载人火箭可以在10年内制造并测试完成。”这些节目产生了显著的效果，因为如果你看看那个十年末的情况，美国人突然间完全相信了：哦，是的，我们可以登上月球。在整个60年代，他们开始真正相信这会在他们有生之年，甚至可能在1980年代之前，很快、迫在眉睫地实现。
But it really took persuasion because it took kind of a fundamental rebrand of what rocketry and physics could accomplish. And that was done through these big magazine features and, you know, these Disney television programs that were watched by lots and lots of people. Pop culture's contribution to space exploration didn't end with Walt Disney. Decades later in the 1990s, not one, but two different movies came out about the Earth being hit by a giant asteroid. And these two movies changed everything about how we think about space.
但这确实需要说服工作，因为它需要对火箭技术和物理学能实现什么进行根本性的品牌重塑。而这一切是通过这些大型杂志专题和那些被许多人观看的迪士尼电视节目完成的。流行文化对太空探索的贡献并没有随着沃尔特·迪士尼而结束。几十年后的1990年代，不仅是一部，而是两部关于地球被巨大陨石撞击的电影上映了。这两部电影改变了我们对太空的所有看法。
What is this thing? It's an asteroid, sir. How big are we talking? Sir, our best estimate is 97.6 billion. It's the size of Texas, Mr. President. Yeah, yes, sir. Yeah, I love these stories because it's like Hollywood being influenced by science
那是什么东西？那是颗小行星，长官。我们说的是多大？长官，我们最好的估计是97.6英里。那是德克萨斯州那么大，总统先生。是的，长官。是的，我喜欢这些故事，因为这就像好莱坞受到科学的影响，
and then science being influenced by Hollywood. Because if you look at Armageddon and Deep Impact, those movies happened at the same time. And the reason that they happened at the same time was, you know was shortly before that, there was an astronomical event called Schumerke-Levy. And essentially what happened was there was a comet that entered the solar system.
然后科学又受到好莱坞的影响。因为如果你看看《世界末日》和《天地大冲撞》，这两部电影是同时期上映的。它们之所以同时出现，是因为在那之前不久，发生了一个名为“苏梅克-列维”的天文事件。本质上发生的事情是，一颗彗星进入了太阳系。
It looked like it was going to crash into Jupiter. And so we pointed the Hubble at it, and then we literally watched a comet crash into Jupiter. And we got pictures of the comet crashing into Jupiter. We had never done that before. We had never seen that happen in real time. And so this was a sensation because we actually got footage like, oh, stuff crashes into things all the time.
它看起来要撞向木星。于是我们将哈勃望远镜对准它，然后我们真的目睹了一颗彗星撞向木星。我们拍到了彗星撞击木星的照片。我们以前从未这样做过。我们从未实时看到过这种情况。这引起了轰动，因为我们真的得到了影像资料，意识到：哦，东西总是会撞到东西。
This is also shortly after this original idea that an asteroid is the thing that killed the dinosaurs emerges. And so you have these two things kind of in the ether, right? Kind of just floating in the air at the time. And then that's what genuinely inspires two films about asteroids potentially coming to hit Earth, or in Deep Impact's case, a comment. And so you have that happen, and then it's years later, it's in 1999, and there's this congressional hearing about this program called Neowise. And Neowise is a near-Earth observatory, and the idea is that NASA wants money so it can
这也是在“小行星导致恐龙灭绝”这一原始观点出现后不久。所以当时这两件事都在以太中，对吧？当时就在空气中飘荡。而这正是激发两部关于小行星可能撞击地球（或者在《天地大冲撞》中是彗星）电影的真正原因。事情就是这样发生的，几年后的1999年，国会举行了一场关于“近地天体广角红外巡天探测器”（Neowise）项目的听证会。Neowise是一个近地观测站，NASA想要资金，以便
count the stuff that's in our neighborhood that's very small and could potentially hit us. And what gets mentioned during this congressional testimony but deep impact on Armageddon. And so you have a situation where these films emerge because of science being done and then they went to inform what eventually became funded through NASA of this Near Earth Object Detection Facility. Media nonfiction and fiction can have a deep impact, pardon the bun accidentally. It can have a significant effect, half of that, on how, you know, leaders actually genuinely perceive the world.
清点我们附近那些非常小、可能撞击我们的东西。在国会证词中被提及的正是《天地大冲撞》和《世界末日》。所以出现了这样一种情况：这些电影的出现是因为科学研究的进展，而它们反过来又为NASA后来资助的“近地天体探测设施”提供了信息。媒体的非虚构和虚构作品确实能产生深远的影响——请原谅我用了这个双关语。它确实能对领导者如何真正感知世界产生重大影响。
But sometimes film and TV can give people the wrong idea about how things work in real life. Think of Bank Heist films. In movies, Bank Heist are usually portrayed as elaborate, almost military-style tactical assaults. But in reality, bank robberies don't look anything like Inside Man or Heat. Bank Heists are really, truly a declining art. And essentially, Hollywood had a very specific idea of what Bank Heist were. They were very informed by Bank Heists of the 1930s and in kind of this
但有时电影和电视会给人们关于现实生活如何运作的错误观念。想想银行抢劫电影。在电影中，银行抢劫通常被描绘成精心策划的、近乎军事化的战术突袭。但实际上，银行抢劫看起来一点也不像《局内人》或《盗火线》。银行抢劫确实是一门正在衰落的艺术。本质上，好莱坞对银行抢劫有着非常具体的想法。它们深受1930年代银行抢劫案的影响，以及那种
like prototypical Bonnie and Clyde style of a takeover, right? Where a bunch of people go in, they brandish guns, they secure the room, and then they empty the safe and then carry things out. It involves a lot of coordination. And you know, that was a type of crime that happened in that era. That's a kind of a professional style of bank robbery that is just no longer as common. Typically what you're going to see now is you get like a note pass and a note that says something threatening, like I have a firearm, I have a bomb, something like that, give me the money and then look at the money. And now typically the main question of whether or not a crime gets solved is, is that person
类似“邦妮和克莱德”式的接管风格，对吧？一群人冲进去，挥舞枪支，控制现场，清空保险库，然后带着东西离开。这涉及大量的协调。你知道，那是那个时代发生的一种犯罪。那是一种现在已经不再常见的专业风格的银行抢劫。通常你现在看到的是，有人递上一张纸条，上面写着威胁的话，比如“我有枪”、“我有炸弹”之类的，然后说“把钱给我”，接着看着钱。现在，犯罪是否能被侦破的主要问题通常是：那个人
able to leave the parking lot before the cops arrive? And so the FBI kept rather detailed statistics on bank crimes over time, and realistically, the idea of a bank takeover was completely out of fashion even in the late 90s. But we still have this idea of like, you know, if you think about bank robbery films, they show lots of different ways to rob a bank. Stay down. We want to hurt no one. We're here for the bank's money, not your money. Your money's insured by the federal government, you're not gonna lose it dying. Think of your families, don't risk your life.
能在警察到达之前离开停车场吗？因此，联邦调查局长期以来一直保留着关于银行犯罪的详细统计数据，实际上，即使在90年代末，银行接管这种想法也已经完全过时了。但我们仍然有这种想法，如果你想到银行抢劫电影，它们展示了许多抢劫银行的方法。“趴下！我们不想伤害任何人。我们是为了银行的钱，不是你们的钱。你们的钱有联邦政府保险，你们不会损失什么的。想想你们的家人，别拿生命冒险。”
Don't try and be a hero. But if a bank robber's normal tactic is passing a threatening note to a teller, there isn't really a great high tech security system that's worth that. But you write that banks and insurance companies still invest in these sophisticated security systems to stop these takeover style bank heists, even though they don't really happen
“别试图当英雄。”但如果银行劫匪的常规战术是给柜员递一张威胁纸条，那么并没有什么真正值得为此投入的高科技安全系统。但你写道，银行和保险公司仍然投资于这些复杂的安全系统来阻止这种接管式的银行抢劫，尽管它们在现实世界中并不怎么发生。这是为什么？你知道，长期以来，银行抢劫的幻想决定了人们对银行安全的需求，不是因为它能让银行里的钱更安全，而是因为人们想看到：哦，他们有摄像头；哦，他们有这个保险柜；哦，他们有定时释放装置。他们实际上是为了让那些习惯了看到这种精心策划的抢劫的客户感到安心，所以他们必须为一家根本不会遭遇这种犯罪的银行做这些相对表演性的事情。
in the real world. Like why is that? You know, the fantasy of a bank robbery for a very long time informed what people wanted in security out of a bank, not because it kept the money safer in the bank, but because people wanted to see, oh, they've got cameras. Oh, they've got this safe. oh, they've got cameras, oh, they've got this safe, oh, they've got this time release, like they were actually, you know, in order just to assure their customers who were so accustomed to seeing this elaborate style robbery that they had to do these somewhat relatively performative things for a given bank that isn't going to actually get this kind of a crime.
是的，人们对银行抢劫的样子有完全错误的观念，因为现在的金融犯罪是在电脑上完成的，这拍不出什么引人入胜的电影。绝对是这样。而且通过加密货币或在线操作，或者任何这类涉及人际说服的骗局，其效率和投资回报率远高于那种暗示性的持枪抢劫，对吧？大胆银行抢劫的浪漫想法在这一点上已经局限于历史了。
Yeah, people have these completely bogus notions about what a bank robbery looks like because now financial crime is done on the computer, which it doesn't exactly make for a compelling movie. Absolutely. And just the efficiency of doing it through crypto or the efficiency of doing it online or any of these kinds of scams that are related to person-person persuasion are vastly higher ROI than just an implied stickup, right? The romantic idea of a daring bank robbery is kind of confined to history at this point.
政府机构知道流行文化在塑造公众舆论方面有多么强大，所以他们学会了利用电影业来服务于他们的目的。美国军方尤其与电影业有着悠久而传奇的关系。军方实际上从一开始就一直在与好莱坞或整个电影业合作。你可以一直追溯到《翼》，这是第一部获得奥斯卡奖的电影，它是在支持下制作的，你知道，你需要飞机，你就会找军方。因此，在20世纪初，双方是非常紧密地联系在一起的。
Government agencies know how powerful pop culture can be in shaping public opinion at large, so they've learned a way to leverage the film industry to serve their purpose. The U.S. military in particular has a long and storied relationship with the movie industry. The military has been collaborating with Hollywood or the film industry in general since really kind of the beginning. You can go all the way back to Wings, which is the first Academy Award-winning film, was made with support, you know, you need planes, you're going to call the military. And so over the course of the early 20th century, it's very much hand in hand.
显然，在二战期间，电影业与五角大楼（或者说当时还在建设中的五角大楼）之间有着巨大的合作。你基本上看到了由沃尔特·迪士尼动画制作的宣传片等等。到了战后，双方仍然渴望合作。
Obviously during World War II, there's an immense collaboration between the motion picture industry and the Pentagon, or the then under construction Pentagon, I should say. And then you basically saw propaganda films made by Walt Disney Animation and so on and so forth. By the time that you kind of get post-war, there's still an eagerness to collaborate between the pairs.
但这实际上对军方来说变得有点争议，因为他们合作了一部名为《最长的一天》的电影，讲述的是诺曼底登陆。“你们今晚的任务是战略性的。不能给敌人喘息的机会。把他们送进地狱。”但不幸的是，他们正在投入
But it actually gets a little controversial for the military because they collaborated on a film called The Longest Day, which was about the D-Day landings. Your assignment tonight is strategic. You can't give the enemy a break. Send them to hell. But unfortunately, they were committing
大量的人力和资源拍摄这部电影，而当时柏林危机正在发生。这让国会极其恼火。因此，这在相当长一段时间内扼杀了军方与好莱坞之间的直接合作。然后经历了越战时期，好莱坞对与五角大楼合作并不感兴趣。就像所有的越战电影，所有那些制作批评美国外交政策机构电影的电影人，五角大楼根本不想与他们有任何瓜葛。因此，结果就是你看到的参与度非常有限。
a lot of men and resources to this film at the same time that the Berlin crisis was going on. And that ticked off Congress to no end. And so that kind of put the Kayabash on a direct collaboration between the military and Hollywood for quite some time. Then you get through the Vietnam era where Hollywood's not really interested in collaborating with the Pentagon. Like all the Vietnam movies, all the filmmakers who were making critical films of the U.S. foreign policy establishment. Pentagon wanted nothing to do with them. And so as a result, you really saw limited engagement.
然后，汤姆·克鲁斯登场了。“我要派你去对抗最优秀的飞行员。”“是的，长官。”“你们两个要去参加壮志凌云。”“我感到需要。对速度的渴望。”本质上，你有了《壮志凌云》的构思。而在《壮志凌云》制作的早期阶段，
And then, enter Tom Cruise. I'm going to send you up against the best. Yes, sir. You two characters are going to Top Gun. I feel the need. The need for speed. And essentially, you have this idea for Top Gun. And very early on in the Top Gun process,
他们基本上联系了海军，说：“这是我们的剧本，我们想拍这部电影。我们认为你们会喜欢这部电影，因为它是一个关于大胆战斗机飞行员的侠义故事。”他们基本上说：“让我们知道你们的想法。”海军审阅后说：“实际上我们认为这里有相当大的合作空间。”“不过我们有一些意见。”所以，你知道，在很早的时候他们就介入了，他们说：“好吧，汤姆·克鲁斯在剧本中的爱人，她在海军工作。她是支援军官。我们不想展示那个。那是我们试图淡化的事情，
they basically reach out to the Navy and they're like, well, here's our script and we'd like to make this film. We think that you guys are gonna like this film because it's a swashbuckling story of a daring fighter pilot. And they basically like, let us know what you think. And the Navy goes over it and they're like, actually we think that there's quite a bit
那种部队内部关系，可以这么说。所以让她成为一名承包商。”另一件事是，我看到了那些本质上是在五角大楼传阅的备忘录，上面写着：“好吧，我们正在对《壮志凌云》中的坏人进行评估。”第一份备忘录是五角大楼韩国事务处打印的，上面写着：“嘿，我们在《壮志凌云》剧本中看到，如果北韩人不是坏人，我们会非常强烈地倾向于此。我们认为半岛目前的情况还可以。不想把事情搞砸。为什么不把他们改成利比亚的卡扎菲呢？”然后在上面用铅笔潦草地写着：
of room for collaboration here. We do have some notes though. And so, you know, very early on they weigh in and they're like, okay, so the love interest of Tom Cruise currently in the script, she works in the Navy. She's a support in the officer. We do not want to show that. That's the thing that we're trying to play down that,
“嘿，这是利比亚事务处。别那样做。就把它改成一个电影中没有命名的随机国家。”因为他们看到这里有一个机会，可以在这种电影中直接影响对美国外交政策以及我们与包括敌对国家在内关系的看法。所以这部电影大获成功。他们对它在留任和招募方面产生的具体影响表现得含糊其辞，但尽管如此，海军，甚至是没有参与这部电影的空军，都看到了人们对成为飞行员的兴趣增加。不仅是人们想加入的频率显著增加，而且对这些单位和军衔内能力的认知也显著提高。
that, you know, inter-troop relations, so to speak. So make her a contractor. The other thing is I saw these documents that were essentially the memos that were sent around the Pentagon saying, okay, we're weighing in on the bad guys and Top Gun. And so the first memo is typed up and it's from the Korea desk at the Pentagon. And it's like, hey, we see in the Top Gun script, we would really strongly prefer if actually the North Koreans were not the bad guys in Top Gun. We think that things are going okay in the peninsula right now. Don't want to mess things up. Why don't you just make them Gaddafi in Libya? And then scrawled in pencil on the top of that
结果，它从根本上改变了军方看待好莱坞的方式。突然间，它从越战时期的“我们不惹那些家伙，他们也不惹我们”，变成了“是的，当然，你可以借用‘亚伯拉罕·林肯号’航空母舰几周，你得给我们开一张象征性的支票，但是的，不，我们喜欢那样。”
type memo is, hey, it's the Libya desk. Don't do that. Just make it a random country that is not named in the film. Because they were seeing that there was an opportunity here to directly influence perceptions of American foreign policy and the relationships that we have, even with adversarial countries, in this kind of film. And so the film is a smash hit. They play coy about exactly the impact that it had on retention and recruitment, but nevertheless, the Navy and even the Air Force, which was not involved with the film, saw an increase in interest in basically becoming a pilot. Significant increase in not only how often people wanted to join, but just the perception of the competence
这确实得到了回报。因为很有趣的是，当第二部《壮志凌云》在过去几年上映时，关于“这是一个有着巨大山脉和海岸线的奇怪虚构国家”的想法有了更多的调侃，你知道，就像无论什么时候——我们都在试图找到一个这样做的国家。但在当时，我想我甚至没有注意到它，你知道，就像在80年代。当然，我当时更年轻、更愚蠢，但即便如此，这就是谈判。就像是：我们会借给你一艘航空母舰，甚至只是穿制服的人，对吧？
within these units and in these ranks. And as a result, it fundamentally changed the way that the military perceived Hollywood. All of a sudden, it went from being the Vietnam era, we don't mess with those guys, they don't mess with us, to yeah, sure, you can borrow the USS Abraham Lincoln for a few weeks, you'll have to cut us a little token check, but like, yeah, no, we love that.
为了你的电影，我们只是得到批准剧本的权利。对于电影制作人来说，这种杠杆作用是一笔你会接受的交易，因为我造不出一艘航空母舰。詹姆斯·卡梅隆也许能，但大多数导演不能。与此同时，他只是说：“好吧，所以他们会得到对剧本的意见，他们会调整它，这样你就不会提到潜在的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）或军中发生的任何性侵犯问题。”
And it really does pay off. Because it was funny when the second Top Gun came out in the last couple of years, there was a lot more joking about the idea, you know, that this was a weirdly fictional country with a large mountain range and a coast, you know, like whenever- We're all trying to find a country that did this. But at the time, I don't think I even registered it, you know, like back in the 80s. Of course, I was younger and dumber than, but still, this is the negotiation. It's like, we will lend you an aircraft carrier or even just like men in uniform, right?
他们会得到他们想要的。然后你会得到你的。你可以借用一艘价值数十亿美元的航空母舰几天。但同样，这确实会影响最终制作出来的电影。绝对是这样。而且你还提到这反过来也成立，政府机构的人看这些电影，并从虚构的政府机构中获得灵感。
For your film, we just get to approve the script. And that amount of leverage is for a filmmaker, that's a deal that you'll take because I can't build an aircraft carrier. James Cameron might be able to, but most directors can't. And then at the same time, he's just like, well, okay, so they'll get their notes on the script, they'll get to tweak it so that you don't mention potentially PTSD or any of the sexual assaults of problems that go on in the military
是的。我最喜欢的一个例子是，有一位从中央情报局（CIA）退休的人叫罗伯特·华莱士，他在技术服务办公室工作，他基本上转述说，一旦一部间谍电影上映并大受欢迎，有时当时负责CIA的人会来找他，说：“顺便问一下，那个我们进展到什么程度了？我什么时候能得到那个？制作它需要多长时间？”比如什么面部识别之类的。
and they'll get theirs. And then you'll get yours. You'll get to borrow a multi-billion dollar aircraft carrier for a few days. But again, it does affect the film you'll get yours. You'll get to borrow a multi-billion dollar aircraft carrier for a few days. But again, it does affect the film that does get made. Absolutely. And you also mentioned that it goes the other way, that people in the government agencies, they watch these movies and they get ideas from fictional government agencies.
某种包含某种东西的小玩意，或者是的。这在可能性范围内，因为它是出现在银幕上的，而且因为用例得到了演示，他们想知道你什么时候能3D打印一张脸并把它戴在汤姆·克鲁斯身上。没错。我的意思是，即使是最近，我读到拜登总统看了《碟中谍7》，他有点被吓到了，
Yeah. So my favorite, there was this guy who retired from the CIA named Robert Wallace who was in the office of technical service and he basically relayed that once a spy movie would come out into cinemas and be a hit, sometimes the guy who was running the CIA at the time would come to him and be like, how far along are we on that, by the way? When do I get that? How long will it take to make it? Like some facial recognition blah, blah, blah.
他实际上签署了一项关于人工智能新安全措施的行政命令。是的。我看到那个的时候我就想：“是的，这很合理。”就像，部分原因是，你看到那种地缘政治动作电影不仅本身是一个有趣的系列电影，而且它们也非常多地反映了国家的焦虑，因为它们可以
Some gadget that contained something or yes. It was within the realm of possibility because it was on screen and because the use case was demonstrated, they want to know when you can 3D print a face and put it on Tom Cruise. That's right. I mean, even pretty recently, I read that President Biden watched Mission Impossible 7 and he got a little spooked
展示人们随着时间的推移而担心什么，并准确地演示：嘿，这是人们，特别是政府，接下来应该担心的。而且他们往往试图保持在头条新闻之前一点点。是的。我是所谓的“能力色情”的超级粉丝。我喜欢看擅长某事的人做某事。比如如果有一部乔治·克鲁尼的电影，像组装和拆卸一个装置，我可以看三个小时。
and he actually signed an executive order with new security measures around AI. Yes. And like I saw that I was like, yeah, that tracks. Like, it's just like, and part of it is that you see specifically with that kind of action in geopolitical action movies are not only, you know, an interesting film series on their own right, but they're also very much a continual reflection of national anxieties because it can just
所以你知道，这些机构有动力向广大公众展示这些令人难以置信的、无可挑剔的、出色的战斗机飞行员，他们无法被击落。这些人就是为军方工作的人。我对警察和警匪剧在这方面的表现非常感兴趣。它们非常受欢迎。我认为它们在塑造人们对犯罪和警务的看法方面起着巨大的作用。我认为这是那种当我们经历这种全国性的骚乱时，
kind of show what people get worried about over time and accurately demonstrate, you know, here's what people and governments in particular should be worrying about next. And oftentimes they try to stay just a little bit ahead of the headlines. Yeah. I'm a huge fan of what I would call competence porn. Like, I love, you know, watching people good at things, do things. Like if there's a movie of George Clooney, like does assembling and reassembling a rival, like I could watch that for three hours.
在乔治·弗洛伊德事件期间，有一群人以一种新的方式看待警察，而其他人则认为：“这就是我们一直看待警察的方式。”而他们正在对抗的事情之一，就是人们因为《法律与秩序》里的斯泰布勒和本森而对警务产生的看法。百分之百。有一种观点认为，我们看的东西是准确的描述，因为它们展示了能干且非常有才华的个人可靠地完成了他们的工作。从广义上讲，这在某种程度上是设计好的。所以如果你看电视上的警匪剧，
So you know, these agencies have this incentive to present the public at large, you know, these incredibly capable, unimpeachable, fantastic fighter pilots who cannot be shot down. Like these are the people that work for the military. And I'm really intrigued by this in terms of police and cop shows. They're extremely popular. I think they have a huge part in shaping people's perception of crime and policing. And I think it's one of those things that when we had this sort of national convulsion
它们是在警察局联络员的协助下制作的，甚至从历史上看，大众文化和大众媒体在警匪剧方面的最早应用就是对警察及其成就的颂扬。所以，就谈谈《法律与秩序》吧。《法律与秩序》首次出现在1990年。从那时到现在，纽约市的凶杀案减少了75%。所以，你知道，在过去的几十年里，由于许多原因，
over policing during George Floyd, there's a whole group of people that saw cops in a new way and other people were like, this is how we've always seen cops. And one of the things that are fighting against is people's perception of policing because of their buddy's Stabler and Benson. 100%. There's this idea that the things that we watch are accurate depictions because they show competent and very talented individuals succeeding at what they do reliably. Broadly speaking, that is kind of by design. So if you look at cop shows on TV,
不仅仅是警务。在大多数北美城市，凶杀案非常明显地减少了。犯罪率总体上也在下降，对吧？然而，美国人认为犯罪率每年都在上升。盖洛普每年都会进行一项调查，询问：犯罪率是上升了、下降了还是和去年一样？大多数人一次又一次地说犯罪率上升了。我认为这里面有问题。因为我认为我注意到的第一件事是，1990年，电视上每年有23集的《法律与秩序》。而现在如果我打开电视，有三部《法律与秩序》。
they're made with the assistance of liaisons from the police department, even historically the earliest applications of mass culture and mass media when it comes to cop shows was the glorification of the police and what they accomplished. And so, like, just to talk about law and order for a bit. Law and order first came out in 1990. Homicides in New York City between then and now have gone down 75%. And so, you know, we have seen over the past several decades because of a number of things,
让我们甚至撇开所有的《法律与秩序》克隆版，比如《FBI》、《芝加哥》系列等等。电视上的《法律与秩序》是原来的三倍。而且电视上纽约市的犯罪率是现在的三倍，而当时的犯罪率比今天高四倍。第二件事我注意到的是，大多数时候，他们赢了。警察抓住了坏人。如果他们没抓住坏人，好吧，他们被释放了，因为司法系统
not simply just policing. Homicides go down very distinctly in most North American cities. And crime go down just in general, right? However, Americans think that crime goes up every year. Gallup runs a survey every single year where they asked, is crime up or down or the same as it was last year? And majority is time and time again say that crime is up. And I think that there's something here. Because I think the first thing that I noticed is that in 1990, there was one law and order on television for 23 episodes a year. And now if I turn on television, there are three law and orders.
根本无法处理。事实并非如此。去年纽约市56%的凶杀案被侦破了，对吧？纽约市凶杀案的结案率，即侦破犯罪率，现在大约是50-50。需要明确的是，这在美国并不反常。部分原因是，犯罪率下降了，但结案率也下降了，这是因为这个国家的警察机构更多地转向了威慑模式。
And let's even set aside all the law and order clones, the FBI's, the Chicago's, what have you. There are three times as much law and order. And there's three times as much crime in New York City on television as there was when crime was four times higher than it was today. And then the second thing that I noticed is that most of the time, they win. The cops find the bad guys. And if they don't find the bad guys, well, they get off because of the justice system
基本上做出的决定是，在每个地铁站、街角安排更多的警察，以威慑犯罪发生的可能性，这比让很多警察坐在总部，等犯罪发生时接到电话去查明是谁干的，然后通过监禁将他们从人口中移除要合理得多。这在电视上没有表现出来。这些节目不是这样运作的，因为部分原因是它们专注于精英单位，对吧？所以他们专注于那些仍然在总部等着电话的人。但结果是，我认为，
just can't handle it. And that is not the case. 56% of homicides were cleared in New York City last year, right? The clearance rate, the solving crime rate in New York City for homicide is about 50-50 now. And that's not abnormal in the United States to be clear. Part of that, crime is down, but clearance rates are down too, is because police agencies in this country have more shifted to a deterrence model.
我们对这个国家的警务工作是什么以及如何运作存在根本性的误解，因为它与我们在电视上看到的格式完全无法识别，不仅是一周一次，而是一晚三次。是的。你知道，在乔治·弗洛伊德去世后，确实有具体的反应，但在那之前，在那之前的一年，主流电视网60%的剧集都是警察程序剧、警匪剧和法律剧。这太多了。对于许多美国人来说，这是他们最可靠的视角，不仅是对警务，而且是对城市，对吧？如果你想，你知道，我住在皇后区，我住在纽约，但如果我打开
The decision was made basically, it makes more sense to have a lot more cops out in every Silicon Hill subway station on the street corners to deter the possibility of crime happening in the first place than it does to have a lot of cops sitting at HQ who then get called when a crime happens to figure out who did it and then remove people from the population by imprisoning them after solving the fact that they've done a crime. That is not represented on television. That is not how these shows operate because part of it is that they focus on elite units, right? And so they're focusing on the people who are still hanging out at HQ waiting for the phone to call. But as a result, I think, you know,
郊区的电视，纽约在银幕上的形象是一个犯罪猖獗的地狱，需要每周一次的特别受害者小组的专门侦探来处理。而且，你知道，这与过去20、30年在这个城市实际发生的事情完全脱节。在你的书中，我对电影中的暴力与现实世界中的暴力之间奇怪的联系很着迷。
we have a fundamental misunderstanding of what and how policing works in this country, because it is completely unrecognizable with the format that we see displayed on televisions, not just once a week, but three times a night. Yeah. You know, there was a reaction specifically following the death of George Floyd, but like, wow, like before that happened, the year before that happened, 60% of dramas on the major networks were police procedurals, cop shows, and legal dramas. And that is a lot. For many Americans, it's their most reliable look, not just at policing, but at cities, right? If you think like, you know, I live in Queens, I live in New York, but like if I turn on
我在一个认为暴力电影会让人兴奋，然后他们会出去犯罪的时代长大。我实际上很惊讶地发现，你知道，这其中有一点点真理。我一直以为这完全是胡说八道。但你也说暴力电影实际上可以降低犯罪率。你能告诉我那个故事吗？百分之百。我痴迷于这个故事，因为我认为它确实改变了我看待媒体能做什么的方式。所以在实验室环境中，如果我们向人们展示暴力意象、
a television from the suburbs, New York's representation on screen is a crime-infested hellhole that requires, you know, the special, the dedicated detectives of the special victims unit services one time a week. And like, you know, that is just out of step with actually what has gone on in this city over the past 20, 30 years. In your book, I was fascinated by the strange connection between violence in the movies and violence in the real world.
暴力视频，他们会变得更加激动。在实验室测试中，他们在被启动后，更有可能对各种不同的事物做出暴力反应或更具攻击性的反应。这是已知的，这已经被重复验证了。所以这两位研究人员，斯特凡诺·德拉·维尼亚和戈登·达尔，他们是经济学家。他们基本上只是想：好吧，有充足的实验室证据表明，向人们展示攻击性意象会使他们更具攻击性。所以人们会认为，如果你像我们在这个国家所做的那样，发行成千上万甚至数百万人观看的暴力电影，如果你有这些全国性的暴力启动事件，你应该能够检测到
I grew up in an era where there was this notion that violent movies, you know, get people riled up and then they go out and commit crimes. And I was actually surprised to know that, you know, there's a little kernel of truth in that. I always thought it was just complete nonsense. But you also say that violent movies can actually bring crime down. Can you tell me that story? A hundred percent. I'm obsessed with this story because I think it has genuinely changed the way that I see what the media can do. So in a laboratory setting, if we show people violent imagery,
在实际的袭击统计数据中。如果你有这种大规模的暴力接触，而且我们知道暴力可能会导致更具攻击性的反应，那应该会在数据中体现出来。所以他们提取了主要美国城市在几年内每个周末的犯罪数据。他们还提取了天气数据，这显然有时是一个对抗性因素，取决于温度。然后本质上他们意识到他们实际上有一个相当有趣的自然
violent videos, they will become more agitative. They will become more likely in lab tests to react violently or react more aggressively to various different things after being primed. This is known, this has been repeated. So these two researchers, Stefano de la Vigna and Gordon Dahl, they're economists. And they were basically just like, okay, there's ample laboratory evidence that showing people aggressive imagery can make them more aggressive. And so one would think that if you, as we do in this country, release violent films that are seen by hundreds of thousands to millions of people, that if you are having these nationwide violence priming events, you should be able to detect that
实验，那就是他们意识到我们（你知道）这里没有“全国暴力电影发行日”。在美国没有特定的日子发行暴力电影。因此，暴力电影可以与同年同一周末发行的非暴力电影进行同类比较。那么这些暴力电影对犯罪数据有什么影响呢？他们不仅没有发现证据表明它增加了袭击，反而发现了它减少了袭击的证据。他们的解释是，如果我，比如说，是一个年龄在
in actual statistics of assaults. That if you are having this mass exposure to violence and we know that violence causes potentially more aggressive reactions, that ought to manifest within the data. And so they pulled crime data for major American cities for which it was available on every single weekend over the course of several years. And they pulled also weather, which is obviously something of an antagonistic factor sometimes depending on the heat. And then essentially they realized that they had an actually rather interesting natural
16到23岁之间的男性，从公共卫生的角度来看，这些人大多数时候表现出非理性的暴力和公开行为。你体内有一堆荷尔蒙，这是人生中一个复杂的时期，大脑没有完全发育，但身体已经发育了，结果，很多人会冲动地进行这类袭击。所以，如果我是那种人，我去看两个小时的暴力电影，你知道，
experiment, which is that they realized that we you know, we don't have released national violent movies day here. There's no specific day in America that we release violent films. And so as a result, violent films can be compared apples to apples to nonviolent films that are released in the same weekend of a given year. So what effect do these violent movies have on crime data? Not only did they not find evidence that it increased assaults, they actually found evidence that it decreased assaults. And their explanation for this is that if I am, let's just say, a man between the ages
提前半小时到，结束后半小时走，喝汽水，吃爆米花，那三个小时是我没有花在外面、没有花在做危险行为的时间，更重要的是，我没有花在喝酒上。而与暴力行为相关联的最大单一因素是酒精。所以你本质上是在做的是
of 16 and 23, which from a public health perspective, those are the people who behave irrationally violent and public most of the time. You have an interest in cocktail of hormones going on, it's a complicated time in life, brains aren't fully developed, but bodies are, and as a result, that's a lot of folks who are going to impetuously do these kinds of assaults. So, if I'm that kind of guy, and I go see a violent film in a cinema for two hours, you know,
调低所有其他风险。你让这些人自我隔离，他们没有去潜在的危险区域，没有潜在地做坏事，而是去看了暴力内容。而启动效应，无论它是什么，都被他们本可以做的其他事情所淹没。这对我来说太神奇了。而且程度之深，以至于超暴力内容在这方面比轻微暴力电影更有效，因为超暴力电影吸引了年轻男性。
get there half an hour early, leave half an hour after, drink soda, eat popcorn, that three hours is three hours that I am not spending outside, I'm not spending doing risky behaviors, and more importantly, I'm not spending it drinking. And the single largest correlated factor to behaving violently is alcohol. And so what you're doing is essentially
是的。理想情况下，你能够把人们隔离在电影院里，你只会给他们看《芭比》，对吧？但实际上，如果你想把人们吸引到电影院，你必须是《小丑》，必须是《电锯惊魂》，必须是类似的东西。是的，是的，但这也意味着如果我想在周五晚上去看《死侍》，
is you're turning down all the other risks. You're having this self sequestration of people who are instead of potentially being dangerous areas, potentially getting up to no good, instead they're seeing something violent. And the priming effect, whatever it may be, is overwhelmingly drowned out by what they would have been doing in lieu of that. That is amazing to me. And it's so much so that ultra-violent things are more effective in this than mildly violent movies because the ultra-violent movies attract the young men.
我会被一群想揍我的17岁笨蛋包围。“这些人中的任何一个都会杀了你，弗罗曼。”休息之后，沃尔特回来告诉我们一个关于美国电影业如何被税法彻底改变的令人惊讶的故事。所以，我们谈了很多关于电影如何影响世界的内容，但你的书中有一个我喜欢的故事。它是关于世界，特别是税法，是如何影响电影制作方式的。
Yeah. Ideally you'd be able to sequester people in cinemas and you would just show them Barbie, right? But like, in reality if you want to get people into the cinema you have to have it be Joker, you have to have it be Saw, you have to have it be something like that. Yeah, yeah, but it also means that if I want to go see Deadpool on a Friday
是的。理想情况下，你可以把人们关在电影院里，只给他们放《芭比》，对吧？但现实是，如果你想把人们吸引进电影院，你得放《小丑》或者《电锯惊魂》之类的电影。没错，没错，但这同时也意味着如果我想在周五晚上去看《死侍》，
night I'm surrounded by 17 year old knuckleheads who want to punch me. Any one of these men would kill you, Froman. After the break, Walt comes back to tell us a surprising story about how the American film industry was completely changed by tax codes. So, we've talked a lot about how movies influence the world, but there was one story in your book that I love. It's about how the world, specifically tax codes of all things, influenced how movies are made.
我会被一群想揍我的17岁小混混包围。弗罗曼，这些人里随便哪个都能杀了你。广告之后，沃尔特会回来告诉我们一个令人惊讶的故事，讲述美国电影业是如何被税法彻底改变的。所以，我们已经谈了很多关于电影如何影响世界的话题，但你的书里有一个我非常喜欢的故事。那是关于世界，特别是税法这种东西，是如何影响电影制作方式的。
Can you tell us that story? Yeah. I was doing a big lit review and I found this one foot note that basically suggested that there's this prevailing theory that, you know, Jaws didn't invent the blockbuster, Gerald Ford did. And I was like, what? And so like I like went back and to the tape and figured out like what on earth is this referring to? And there was basically a tax reform that was passed in 1976 that directly changed the way that movies could be funded, where from 1970 to 1976 a very popular form
你能给我们讲讲那个故事吗？好的。当时我正在做大量的文献综述，偶然发现了一个脚注，它基本上暗示了一种流行的理论，即《大白鲨》并没有开创大片时代，而是杰拉尔德·福特。我当时就想，什么？于是我回去查阅了资料，想弄清楚这到底是指什么。基本上，1976年通过的一项税制改革直接改变了电影的融资方式，而在1970年到1976年间，一种非常流行的电影融资形式出现了。
of funding of film happened. You have to remember that at the time, the top marginal tax rate was 80, 90 percent, so if you were like a wealthy dentist, that last dollar that you make is mostly going on Uncle Sam. And so there became this kind of scheme. There was an article in Business Week that was called How to Make Money in Mo- And it like talked to these folks,
这种融资方式发生了。你得记住，当时最高边际税率高达80%到90%，所以如果你是一个富有的牙医，你赚的最后那一美元大部分都要交给山姆大叔。于是就出现了一种方案。当时《商业周刊》有一篇文章叫《如何通过电影赚钱》，它采访了这些人，
like there was articles like, hey, I'm in tax magazine, here's how you should do this stuff. Here's all that you gotta do. And like Bloomberg Business Week had an entire subsection of a feature in the early 70s, basically saying here's how to make money by investing in movies. Basically you would get a bunch of wealthy people
比如有文章说，嘿，我在税务杂志上看到，你应该这样做。这就是你需要做的全部。而且像《彭博商业周刊》在70年代初有一个专题的完整子版块，基本上就是在说如何通过投资电影来赚钱。基本上，你会召集一群富有的人，
who would put money into a project, they would take out a big loan, invest all the loan into developing the film, and then that would come off to the IRS as a very significant loss on your taxes, even though you only put in a little bit, so you saved a bunch of money. And then that movie would get made, get released, and then you'd get proceeds of it. And sometimes it would make money, sometimes it wouldn't, sometimes it would make a lot of money, right? Sometimes you would get a one flu over the cuckoo's nest
他们会为一个项目投入资金，他们会申请一大笔贷款，把所有的贷款都投入到电影开发中，然后这在国税局看来就是你税收上的重大损失，尽管你只投入了一点点，所以你省下了一大笔钱。然后那部电影会被制作出来，发行，然后你就能获得收益。有时它会赚钱，有时不会，有时会赚很多钱，对吧？有时你会得到像《飞越疯人院》
or shampoo or dog day afternoon. And that was very popular for a number of years. And then the IRS got wise to it and they were like, we don't want this to happen anymore. Please stop this Congress. And so in 1976, they passed this tax reform act. And so typically people understand Jaws came out. It was a huge blockbuster, changed everything. After Jaws came out, everyone else just started making Jaws. And that's when the era of the blockbuster movie started. And what this illustrated was that that's not wrong. Jaws was a huge hit and people made a lot of movies that looked like Jaws, Studio Funded, Studio Director, Studio Cast, Studio, this kind of stuff, all kind of internally funded. But that's not the whole picture. It's
或者《洗发水》、《热天午后》这样的作品。这在很多年里都非常流行。后来国税局发现了这一点，他们说，我们不想再让这种情况发生了。请国会停止这种行为。于是，在1976年，他们通过了这项税制改革法案。所以通常人们认为《大白鲨》上映了。它是一部巨大的大片，改变了一切。在《大白鲨》上映后，其他所有人都开始制作《大白鲨》式的电影。这就是大片时代开始的时候。但这说明了那并不完全正确。《大白鲨》确实非常成功，人们制作了很多看起来像《大白鲨》的电影，由制片厂资助、制片厂导演、制片厂演员、制片厂内部资助等等。但这并不是全部情况。它
like an extinction level event happened for every other kind of movie out there that they couldn't make anymore because of this tax cleverness that was no longer permitted. And so a whole kind of class of film could no longer get made. And so the only kind of film that could get made was the Studio Back Productions. That's so interesting because that whole idea of a bunch of dentists giving you the money to do a movie is like such a thing that I didn't understand what people were talking about when they said it. But like I've heard of that before.
就像是其他所有类型的电影都遭遇了灭绝级别的事件，因为这种不再被允许的税务技巧，它们无法再被制作出来。因此，一整类电影都无法再被制作了。所以唯一能制作出来的电影就是制片厂支持的作品。这太有趣了，因为那种一群牙医给你钱拍电影的想法，我以前根本不明白人们在说什么。但我确实听说过。
Sometimes they're being quite literal. Like James Cameron made Xenogenesis, I think, he was like his first feature. It ended up being a short, but he basically just went to the dentist in town. And I think two dentists put up some checks for him. And then the movie was good enough with the special effects that Roger Corman was like, all right, you're with me, Jimmy.
有时他们说的是字面意思。比如詹姆斯·卡梅隆制作了《异形起源》，我想那是他的第一部剧情片。最终它成了一部短片，但他基本上就是去找镇上的牙医。我想有两位牙医为他开了支票。然后这部电影的特效足够好，以至于罗杰·科曼说，好吧，你跟我干吧，吉米。
And then got him into the industry as a result. You can see a lot of directors kind of got their start making that kind of film. They got people to take a risk on them to make that kind of film. And structurally, is the industry succeeding at that anymore? There is some of that in the independent space, but you did kind of have a situation where the IRS was vaguely subsidizing the generation that would become
结果他因此进入了电影行业。你可以看到很多导演都是通过制作那种电影起家的。他们让人冒险投资他们去制作那种电影。从结构上讲，这个行业现在还能做到这一点吗？在独立电影领域确实有一些，但你确实遇到过一种情况，即国税局在某种程度上补贴了那一代人，他们后来成为了
New Hollywood in a lot of different ways. And then, you know, when that went away, it significantly changed the entire market for how you could make a movie. Yeah. Yeah. This is great. The book is so much fun. People are gonna have so much fun reading it. Thank you so much for talking with me. I appreciate it. Thank you for having me. I really dig the show. This was a real treat.
新好莱坞，以各种不同的方式。然后，你知道，当这种情况消失后，它显著改变了整个电影制作的市场。是的。是的。这太棒了。这本书非常有趣。人们读起来会非常开心。非常感谢你和我交谈。我很感激。谢谢你邀请我。我真的很喜欢这个节目。这真是一种享受。
Walt Hickey's book is out now. It's called You Are What You Watch, How Movies and TV Affect Everything. It's got cool charts. It's got pictures. It's got short stories that you'll love. Probably one touching on your favorite movie franchise. You should definitely check it out.
沃尔特·希基的书现在已经出版了。书名是《你就是你所看的：电影和电视如何影响一切》。里面有很酷的图表。有图片。还有你会喜欢的小故事。可能其中一个就触及了你最喜欢的电影系列。你一定要去看看。
99% invisible was produced this week by Sarah Bake with assistance and mixing by Martin Gonzales, music by Swan Real. Kathy too is our executive producer. Kurt Colestead is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason De Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Laushamadhan, Jacob Maldonado-Madina, Nina Pottock, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
本周的《99%隐形》由莎拉·贝克制作，马丁·冈萨雷斯协助并负责混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔创作。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德·莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、劳沙马丹、雅各布·马尔多纳多-麦地那、尼娜·波托克、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格和我，罗曼·马斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. Home of the Oakland Roots Soccer Club, of which I'm a proud community owner. Other teams may come and go, but the roots are Oakland first. Always. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our newly launched Discord server.
我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一员。现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。这里是奥克兰根足球俱乐部的主场，我是该俱乐部的骄傲社区所有者。其他球队可能会来来去去，但根基永远属于奥克兰。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们新推出的Discord服务器。
We're on there talking about the Power Broker and our favorite architecture. There's even like a movie channel. We can talk about what you're watching. And you can find a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们在那里讨论《权力掮客》和我们最喜欢的建筑。甚至还有一个电影频道。我们可以讨论你正在看什么。你可以在99PI.org找到相关链接以及《99%隐形》的所有往期节目。目前该剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。